i bring you now to twitter number one
united states trend alexandria
ocasio-smallette
and number three is kyle right now so
we'll get into that later which is it's
a crazy day i guess all
filled with all sorts of drama but
here's here's the the actual big news
from red state
aoc wasn't even in the capitol building
during her near-death experience
this isn't just one story all right i
mentioned this the other day we
ragged on the idea of the drama because
the drama was aoc was like yo the
capital thing happened and i was scared
and i went
okay i get it and then michael tracy was
like that's manipulation
and then the media picked this up and
made the story about michael tracy
tweeting at aoc and then the young turks
is like oh smackdown i'm like dude i
don't care
i don't care the news about aoc telling
a story and then some journalists
criticizing her so what
well the story today is actually
substantially different aoc now has
three big lies one that she feared for
her life this is the first thing she
said i was scared
i was gonna die that day the next ted
cruz you almost had me killed in the
third
i was terrified because the rioters were
coming and you know there the cop was
was banging on my door i don't know
what's going on and
i was hiding she wasn't even there now
she responded
to this claim saying that's a smear
taking advantage of people who don't
understand the capital complex
so jack posobik posted an image showing
that the building she was in was across
the street it's not the same building
but there's tunnels tim
there's tunnels you don't know about the
time i know about the tunnels no that
was her response but they didn't go in
the tunnels they're also
connected through electricity okay and
this thing called wi-fi
and internet i mean they're all
interconnected so i mean they could have
came through the phones jumped out who
knows
now the look i try i refrain for the
most part from criticizing parts of her
story today because i want to get in the
drama
one of the aspects of her story was that
while she was hiding from the mob
apparently
she had her staffers in the lobby like
what like to confront the mob
for her it's insane they should all have
been hiding white people to the front
i don't even the person was white but
but more importantly
it just wasn't a true story yeah it was
at at best in her case a total
embellishment
that uh okay i get it people they did
they did evacuate the building where her
office is and that was because there
were concerns about maybe a bomb threat
or something but
nothing to do with the writers and so
she's telling the story of her like
pinned up against the wall scared the
rioters were coming
tons of news outlets actually wrote that
the riders were storming the building
they didn't even fact check any of this
she wasn't even in the building
imagine the goal to understand that the
country is so much in trouble
so divided and what do you do in that
moment
look at me i almost died and he almost
killed me i mean that's absolutely
insane there's a meme
going around with her that famous photo
of her at the border where she kind of
kneels down and she's crying
and they kind of replaced it with her
watching the tv of the capital riots and
that means going around viral right now
because again you have to understand
here you know she also
interjected this is not that she just
talked about it randomly offhand
she interjected when people were having
a populist reddit revolt on
on wall street with the wall street vets
she interjected that with this
particular story which we're learning is
just
absolutely nonsensical so ask yourself
was it
spontaneous was it deliberate was it
intended to bring attention back to the
fact that there's been an insurrection
and there's domestic terrorists and
she's getting out in front now
messaging for a roll out of counter
insurgency and counter domestic
terrorism and censorship
and censorship all kinds of things she
has to keep the story alive keep the
emotion alive
to to just lay down some groundwork for
legislation and action did you also
happen to notice today
that npr and reuters both running
stories from brennan
saying that we need to to to take the
lessons that we learn from battling
insurgents in iraq and afghanistan and
used those same tactics here against
people in the united states npr was
running that story
interviewing a cia agent that was a part
of
fighting counter insurgency in the
middle east and he's like we need to do
this we need to go after trump
it's crazy he literally said this former
cia guy to npr
that we have to treat the people who
follow trump like isis or al qaeda
npr by the way national public radio not
a national company it's a private
company
right to non-profit i believe yeah but
uh
they're now going to start bringing the
domestic the war on terror home domestic
glenn greenwald warned about it of
course and i i love it i love it
but no no no i'm saying i love the media
scenario you gotta let me finish
i i love that all of a sudden you now
have these
leftists who claim to be
anti-authoritarian
suckling the teat of the security state
and cheering it on
cheering for 25 000 troops coming to d.c
cheering for a
permanent green zone barbed wire fences
surrounding the capitol
cheering for 5 000 national guard
permanently remaining
in dc cheering for aoc as she
manipulates
and tells these hoax stories in order to
generate the ability
to swing public opinion to generate the
swing in public opinion to support
more authoritarian lockdown the
tactics that they learned in iraq and
afghanistan to manage
an insurgency are things like this hire
local gangs to carry out assassinations
use bribery and intense intense uh
incentives use drone strikes in the
middle of the night
like just make people disappear we also
have to understand
this insane notion of an insurrection
when the united states went there
to their country they're not
insurrecting against anything they're
mad about guys coming into their country
and then killing their people and then
dropping drone bombs on them
so how how dare you even call them
insurrectionists they're people who are
fed up who are wearing flip-flops who
don't even know where the united states
is or even the concept of the united
states most of them talk about
afghanistan yes
yes i mean it's absolutely insane to
understand you know the situation in
afghanistan for my personal friends who
are vets
who are saying a lot of these guys don't
even know anything about the united
states they don't even care about what
we do
they just want to live their life and
most of them are goat herders i want to
point out the united states
is an insurrection against the british
monarchy let that be remembered
started as so but let me read the story
from the from red state they say
newsweek even claimed that aoc they said
this
ocasio-cortez said that rioters actually
entered her office forcing her to take
refuge inside her bathroom
after her legislative director geraldo
bonilla chavez told her to hide hide run
and hide
and so i run back into my office she
said okay
said i slam my door there's another kind
of like back area to my office and i
open it
and there's a closet in the bathroom and
i jump into my bathroom it turns out
however
that wasn't true they they had to fact
check and start retracting all this
because
it wasn't true they say as it turns out
however my colleague banshee reported
earlier
aoc said in her instagram drama that the
person who came to her office was a
capital police officer
but she denigrated the officer who came
to help claiming he didn't feel right
and that he was looking at her in all
this anger and hostility they go on a
mention
but a few important things to note that
seem to have been left out of the whole
story
aoc wasn't even in the capitol building
where all the action was going down
if she was in her office she was in the
cannon building which is nearby but a
different
building but of course many didn't get
the logistics and just assumed
that she was in the capitol building
according to rep nancy mace a republican
from south carolina
who has an office in the same hall as
aoc two doors away there were never
any rioters in their hall so there was
never any physical danger from the
riders coming in at any point
aoc tells this story making it seem like
the rioters are coming
taking advantage of the fact that people
don't know where her office is
not in the capitol building and in
response we see this from her
she said all right let me let me slow
down jack bosok tweeted
tweeted the story aoc wasn't in the
building aoc responds
this is the latest manipulative take on
the right they are manipulating the fact
that most people don't know the layout
of the capital complex
we are we were all on the capital
complex the attack wasn't just on the
dome
the bombs trump supporters planted
surrounded our offices too
aoc took advantage of the fact that
people didn't know they didn't know
when she said oh the writers and i was
hiding my office most people just
assumed
her office was in the capitol building i
did i did too i did too
she was so proud because she was telling
the story about the riots and everything
i assumed that she was in this building
when it's when
when it turns out it's not true and she
was lying she says
we're the ones or or jack pasovic or the
right are the ones
manipulating so here's what jack pasobic
tweeted
a a picture from google maps here's the
us capitol building
and then you can see cross the street
and you have katie porter's office
and then you have the that's in the
longworth house office building
across the street from that is the
cannon house office building where aoc
is
she was kitty corner to the capitol
building in a different
building they didn't go in the tunnels
they went into the capitol building when
jack pointed this out ayo said
you were what about the tunnels they
weren't in the tunnels we know they
weren't in the tunnels
that wasn't the news story so it's a
month later
and she comes out with another story
i'll mind you conveniently around the
time that people are
are staging an insurrection of doing air
quotes against wall street
and totally shifts the narrative and we
get to some stupid drama news cycle
where they're just like oh michael tracy
is a journalist and he said some mean
things about her
and the day goes by and everyone's like
you guys realize that she doesn't work
in the capitol building right
and then i didn't i didn't i didn't
bother to look into the story you know
why
i didn't care to cover it who cares yeah
it's silly drama so she was scared
look like i mentioned aoc comes out and
says i was scared i say i respect that
look i'm not gonna i'm not gonna look
jack you're you're at six foot five or
whatever
if you told me that you you know you
weren't scared i'd say sounds about
right
and aoc is you know like what five seven
and she's like a you know just
she's not no experience in this kind of
situation i say okay she's scared
can we move on what's the point yeah no
no use arguing whatsoever
but my question to you guys do you think
that she just spontaneously sat down and
started weeping on instagram
or do you think that this was
intentional i think she's associated
always intentionally well this is the
thing
this is not part of a larger this is
this is what we have to remember
she also was photo opt crying at a fence
looking at an empty parking lot a couple
months ago that's very true so
i mean the the photos very clear it was
at the immigration camps
there wasn't anything there it was an
empty parking lot and she's weeping and
crying and those photos went viral and
there was big stories about this and
this is
again rinse and repeat use emotion in
politics to skew
anyone's rational thinking and critical
thinking skills which are out the door
because
we have a lady that's crying we have to
do our
what is it called we have to we have to
you know white knight as well and
support her i love the meme
where it's like a crudely drawn
paintbrush meme and it says oh no she's
crying
quick burn the constitution yeah that's
the only way when i say it's always
intentional what i mean is when you make
internet videos they're
you're always doing it on purpose you
never like accidentally in your in your
most vulnerable state
get online and make an internet video
it's a process
yes and we've seen a ton of youtubers do
this where they start
they start filming themselves and
they're like i'm just so sad
and i needed to tell you all it's like
you you turned the camera on and then
started crying for the camera like
breakup videos they're so annoying
aoc has really like taken this new
internet drama culture of reality tv
much like trump did from
from terrestrial television bringing it
into politics she's bringing the same
kind of drama garbage nonsense reality
tv from the internet
into the political world and it is gold
it's platinum i'm afraid it's driving
her kind of crazy i went through it as a
youtuber when and then
with the things you think they love you
for you want to do more of and if you
think they like you because you're crazy
you want to be crazier and then you want
to be crazier and like try and top
yourself
and to see that in a politician is
terrifying i think she knows what she's
doing i think she's a careerist i think
that's why i'm like i don't care to talk
about her telling her story the fact
that she's now jesse smalletted
everybody
and we all just assumed she was in the
capitol building that's that's huge
imagine if she went through what rand
paul went through a couple days ago when
he went through a black lives matter
protest rand paul i was there i saved
him
yeah what saved grandpa we have rand
paul at like two o'clock in the morning
i was out on the protest it was the
night of the republican national
convention and they didn't have any
security out in the street and i spent
all night
escorting people from the the convention
from the white house back to their
hotels guiding them around rioters and
mobs and stuff
and as i was getting ready to leave
there was rand paul and i went up to him
like dude you can't be here
and we bought some time in space and we
finally got some cops over there
he got attacked he got attacked because
they said why won't you support brianna
taylor when he's literally the guy who
wrote the debris on the tailored bill
yup he wrote it
but they assume like it's a republican
get him yeah it's like it's rand paul
dude
no they don't like them they don't care
yeah aoc comes out and talks about you
know the first criticism she got for the
story
from a lot of people was i wonder what
the people who lost family members
during the black lives matter riots are
thinking right now when you're claiming
that you know you were scared for your
life but think about how
how despicable this is now not only
are you know look i don't like these
games where they're like well the black
lives matter you know riots did all this
damage so you should be talking about
them i don't like that you know why
they're different things aoc is allowed
to be like yo i was scared
it has nothing to do with what happened
with black lives matter if you're mad
that she she didn't call it out we can
say
i i'm so sorry this happened to you like
i mean that sincerely it's a horrible
thing
and uh i'll get your back my only my
only request is just
to pay attention to other people who
feel this who feel similarly i don't
think it's a it's a one-up game
but now i'm pissed because now it's not
only does she defend
well protests are supposed to make
people uncomfortable not only does
kamala harris bail out these riders who
burn down cities
literally got people killed aoc now
fabricates the story
of you know what went down when i
actually have uh
one tweet where someone actually points
out that aoc even changed her story
day over day where first she was saying
that she didn't go to the extraction
point
because she was worried about the other
congress people and i did a big segment
about this on my main channel
about how the democrats are scared
republicans will kill them because aoc
was saying i'm worried about what
they'll do to me
she was telling how you know during the
capital riots i didn't want to go with
the republicans and be in the same place
with them
later she's now saying that maybe she
didn't get the extraction point
information because the officer was
withholding it
like the story changed a month later she
is purposefully turning on her live
stream
and telling a sob story my question is
you brought you bring up a good point
jack
why why is she bringing this up right
now it's been a month
and she goes they're trying to tell me
to move on i'm not telling you to move
on i'm wondering why it is you
purposefully chose to start a late night
prime time live stream telling a fake
story
exaggerating what went down and
denigrating the cop who actually tried
to save your life
if it was true that you were in the
capitol building like everyone assumed
and maybe it's not her fault because
people just assumed it but that could be
it's a manipulation tactic to leave out
key details to make people assume things
i don't know if she has the savvy to
actually pull that off maybe she does
but i think she does i think she's
extremely cynical i don't think people
give her enough credit i think we think
she's silly and ditzy
i think she's incredibly cynical and the
fact that she brought in the like the
race of the people who are being
affected like treating the cop like he
was after her because
her skin tone it's like that's something
uh intense for when you're feeling super
emotional
if she's telling us this story about
riders coming to get her it was bad
enough
she was insulting the cop who was
risking his life to save her when
another cop already lost his
life now it turns out this cop was
probably just walking through an empty
building
and he probably knocked on the door
probably not even that bad and said oh
wait where is she
oh [ __ ] you can come out what's go go to
the go to go to katy porter what's up
with the bombs i heard about
bombs surrounding yeah there were there
were pipe bombs i guess right okay
she never said she was in the capitol
building in this from what i know so she
didn't overtly lie to people she just
omitted information assuming that people
knew
no no but now she's saying when jack
bosobic put out the story she's like
this is misinformation
they don't understand the capital
complex she's trying to defend the idea
that she was getting
and the mainstream media was running
with the story she was at the capitol
many of them and if if you're in that
position
you're supposed to fix them you're
supposed to correct them as the person
who's telling the story
so people don't assume but not only that
she may not have said i was in the
capitol building
she was telling a story about how the
rioters were potentially coming for her
and she was hiding from them
they weren't they were across the street
in a totally different building no she
it was just madness and chaos so she
didn't know where they were
she knew they weren't in the building
and when you say if you're at the
capitol complex you're at the capitol
even if you're not in the capital
building you're still at the capitol is
the way i think
the phrase it's irrelevant bro look look
i i was i wasn't at the capitol building
that day but i was downtown i was on
pennsylvania avenue i saw what was going
on i felt the energy
dude even i could tell that there was
something off right there was energy in
the air that wasn't usually there
and it was unsettling to me and when i
was like getting the reports of the
riots at capitol i was like i'm not i'm
not going down there
so i can understand if she was
uncomfortable i totally can
the lying i even understand that people
embellish
she's on instagram she's talking her
heart and whatever
but the timing and why
now why now at the same time as all this
news about domestic counter intelligence
or counterterrorism
and battling insurgencies and doubling
down on people being terrorist groups
and insurgents
and and suppression of civil rights and
coming after people and detrompification
i think it's smokescreen i think it's i
mean it's meant to get us to do this
like why didn't she talk around and talk
about it instead of like
being more focused on what the cia and
the fbi and everybody are going to do
but i disagree we
talked about the other day we're
literally talking about the cia and the
fbi in this context and how it's
dangerous that aoc's
emotional story which is fabricated is a
manipulation tactic that will allow
the the federal government to expand
national security powers and shout out
to rashida tolay once again for for
being the one person who says we can't
allow the government to expand their
their security powers on this
meanwhile aoc is the one who's feeling
the fire to do it do you think that that
signifies a crack in the squad you know
honestly i i
look back at a lot of the news and i
don't i don't know if rashida toled was
always
completely in alignment more so that
they were kind of fellow travelers in a
sense
that uh their interest aligned for a
time for the time being and
uh i i'm not gonna be able to pull up
all of the other examples where i've
been like oh that's interesting that
richard taleb wasn't agreeing with aoc
on this one but notably the omnibus
spending bill
where she played voted against that and
so did tulsi gabbard and i said wow
that's really cool for shitlay that was
the right move
more republicans voted no on it tulsi
gabbard voted no on it i wish
you know more people voted no on it what
would be amazing is to have her on the
show
so if anyone knows her it has
connections to rashida to telev
please come down please message us we
would love to have you and i think that
would be an awesome amazing importance
i've probably said some very disparaging
things about her in the past like
very critical i'm i'm pretty i'm pretty
much we'll be fair like we are to
everyone else but
she's obviously you know providing a
perspective that's very critically
important and for
a wider audience to understand that i
think is critical right now
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you